you
what do you desire honor and pride
power and influence money and riches
revenge or to transcend all such things
for what reason do you risk your life to
climb the tower
[Music]
I whatever you desire you will find it
here
welcome to the tower of God
climb the tower and everything will be
yours at the top exists everything in
this world and all of its can be yours
you can become a god this is the story
of Rachel
the girl who climb the tower so she
could see the stars and bomb the boy who
needed nothing except her this is their
end and their beginning
[Music]
tell me something dog a day I wanna know
everything to be afraid don't know the
answer but we can we'll climb in ready
boundaries a 15-2 pitch to me is never
gonna stop until the words I say
the heart attack cause it can't see
[Music]
let's go
let you go never let you go can I see
them
[Music]
I'm sorry
bond Rachel just wait forget about me
please no
[Music]
forgive me Bom you know I have to climb
the tower
yeah don't leave me don't go just pray
for me pray that I'll be reborn
[Music]
Rachel
the answer can always be found at the
top of the tower
[Music]
what is this place a place where all
visitors are welcome I am head-on the
caretaker of this tower tower
yeah tower this is it
really it's a pleasure to meet you my
dear master bomb wait a minute how do
you know my name you so raychel you
talked with her
I followed her here I was trying to get
to the answer can always be found at the
top of the tower at the top of the tower
she went up there will you take the test
the one required to climb the tower what
kind of test
the rules are simple
you will enter the cage if you break the
ball while avoiding the white steel eel
you pass the test will you take it if
you wish to turn back now is the time
the tower is dangerous for someone like
you how'd you know neo ninja kabu he
sanal Chetta Hawaii
[Music]
yousa doen Iannetta judicata cool you
understand us now right yeah that
high-quality pockets too good for you
you don't deserve it pocket it's not
just a translator it's also our lifeline
in the tower face toward it and then say
invisible mode invisible no don't look
so shocked by the way if you say visible
mode it'll move you were an irregular
right off the bat I'm not sure I know
what an area outsiders who managed to
enter the tower by opening the gates on
their own yeah whatever but you look
kind of weak to be an irregular I don't
get it
why are we getting involved with an
irregular anyway are you trying to say
that you could care less if the whites
Delisle turns them into sushi for
breakfast you maybe you're a princess of
jihad but if the King were to learn of
this you would be executed am I wrong
that's only if you blab to the king Lady
Yuri I devote myself to maintaining
order in the tower and ensuring the
royal families prosperity therefore I am
simply doing my job then why give him an
unfair test even the guys on the 20th
floor have trouble dealing with that
oversized deal in the stainless steel
tux unfair may I respectfully remind you
that he's a nun regular as a guy do you
sense any hidden powers within him could
there be any chance he'll suddenly
transform I have to admit he seems
fairly agile they're even Evan says so
although you'll also have to admit how
puny and frail he looks but if you put
my back against a wall I'd admit he's a
bit handsome head-on couldn't you drop
the level of his test a teensy-weensy
bit just this one time
I am caretaker of the tower it is
necessary to determine if he is worthy
of it yes but be okay
what I don't know who you are I
appreciate your consideration you don't
even recognize the princess of jihad
you're actually going to try to climb
the tower when you're that ignorant are
you trying to die it's a lot better than
just giving up isn't it oh if you're so
determined to have him climb the tower
princess Yuri then why not lend him the
blanket March depending on who wields it
as I'm sure you are aware the legendary
sword of jihad can be a lump of lead or
a blade that cuts through anything
hold on there only a princess of jihad
can wield the black March do you have an
inkling of what had happened if word got
out that another wheeled offensive
inventory visible mode activate lady
Yuna
listen to me I'm going to let you borrow
this for now Lady Yuri but that's an
amazing sword that's right but do you
want to climb the tower or not
I can't believe you really let him
borrow the sword you're the one who told
me to give it to him I promise to give
it back after I break the ball first
worry about staying alive then think
about the rest alright got it Lady Yuri
honestly have you fallen in love with
him at first sight he quiet you don't
truly believe in a regular will change
the tower that's absurd don't be stupid
you know how much I detest being bored
come on that's all this is the truth is
there's only one way to pass this test
[Music]
if you provide any more assistance you
will fail do you want me to just watch
and die
it is the path each Oh get out of my way
that's not quite the proper way to
address me yeah you may be the caretaker
but wait Larry stop go kid did the right
thing huh he did the what it's
impossible to escape from the white
steel Eve
so rather than flee you have no choice
but to face it and leap into its mouth
[Music]
[Applause]
overcoming the fear of death is the true
answer to this test
he entered its mouth knowing he would
have stabbed the heel if you already
knew the answer why didn't you just
simply tell him even if someone already
knows the answer they usually aren't
able to do anything so apparently
ridiculous at that point he has
something even stronger than the fear of
death he has something that allowed him
to face that fear and conquer it forever
what the real test hasn't even begun yet
[Music]
what's going on
why haven't he destroyed the ball I'm
afraid I can't answer that what what are
you planning now caretaker
[Music]
what are you what are you doing down
there wait I'm coming for you
you see so you don't remember anything I
guess that must be scary but now it's
okay you don't have to worry I'm here
with you I want to see the stars stars
at the top of the tower there's a thing
called the sky it stretches out forever
and ever
they say it's full of countless
beautiful shining stars then they must
be just like you and where did you learn
to say something like that Bom I'm just
so tired sick and tired of being in this
dark red red Rachel don't leave me
other peers he was a bit too loud that's
not good run newbie run run hurry hey
newbie listen you have to talk to the
black March ask it for its power now
Evan are you out of your mind or what
that's sword won't listen to what I tell
you right now grab me your strength
[Music]
boy
you search for the strength with which
to climb the tower
no actually hmm I'm not interested in
climbing it but I beg you please grab me
your strength so that I may see Rachel
one more time such a boy but since you
have such a divine face I shall grant it
just this once she's not Hey
she never granted me her strength no
matter how many times I asked maybe she
just prefers men correct so now it's
time for you to go woman so the legend
of the tower is real after all it's not
fair I won't accept it
[Music]
what the hell
what what happened just now you mean you
don't know he has ascended to the next
level
okay fine terrific so now what he still
has two black March and that's not good
what are we supposed to do we just have
to get it back that's all huh we're
going after him whoa whoa hang on a
second we're forbidden from entering the
testing grounds for climbing the tower
get moving how life were nothing
interesting ever happens is it worth a
[__] well guide what are you standing
around for
hey wait she's stubborn what a
fascinating gathering this has been
[Music]
I look forward to seeing what happens
next very intriguing even if the two of
you are reunited things will never be
exactly as they once were when you meet
her again she will have lived for some
time about you
but first sleep the road ahead is
fraught with danger
[Music]
testing testing one two three testing
hello regulars and welcome to the second
floor of the tower this testing floor
will determine which of you are worthy
applying the rest of the tower and now
let's get the first test started the
rules are quite simple in total there
are 400 of you regulars here please
reduce that number to 200 within the
allotted time frame of course you may
use whatever methods you wish please
keep in mind at the moment only 200
regulars remain standing the test will
come to an end
also remember that you can check the
number of regular standing and the time
remaining on the test
[Music]
[Applause]
so we are you there's no point in ruling
somebody begging for your life no
impunity
[Music]
you and my way in order to make it to
the next floor I have to survive somehow
huh and just why are you trying to kill
me
survival's the only way to win these are
the rules of the chest you stupid fool
and I see the inferior mind so easily
allows itself to be manipulated and
controlled in order to survive to climb
the tower I have no choice
that was a mistake this is the hunters
position don't give me that crap how
about I toss you away to damage it
you'll pay for this
no where is the good prey hmm what is it
our sense
that lizard no that weapon
another formidable presence that weapon
now it's mine to do this they have to
don't bother the way your knees are
shaking I doubt you could catch a rabbit
in a cage
[Applause]
maybe you'd be better off pointing that
sword at that guy over there
[Music]
maybe become sober living but I don't
wanna be alone so can you tell me to you
now
[Music]
you